(machines beeping)
(gasps)
- You're dead, Wheeler.
Dead.
♪ We can beat them ♪
♪ Forever and ever ♪
- Dude, Troy peed himself.
(crowd laughs)
- Holy shit.
- Mike, don't.
- [Boy] Four, three, two.
- Mike.
- [Boy] One.
(yells)
♪ I will be king ♪
♪ And you ♪
♪ You will be queen ♪
♪ Though nothing ♪
♪ Will drive us away ♪
♪ We can be heroes ♪
♪ Just for one day ♪
♪ We can be us ♪
(yells)
- She broke my arm.
My arm.
- Go.
- Yeah that's right, you better run.
She's our friend and she's crazy.
You come down here and she'll kill you.
You hear me?
She'll kill you sons of bitches.
She'll kill you.
(screams)
- Come on wake up, El, you okay?
Can you move?
Help her up.
♪ And we kissed ♪
♪ As though nothing could fall ♪
- Will is that you?
It's Mike, do you copy?
Over.
- Will.
- Do you know where he is?
Do you know where Will is?
- [Will] Stop it, you're scaring her.
- She should be scared.
- No.
- Oh.
It's okay.
I got you, I got you.
I got you.
You did so good.
- What should we do?
- Call the police.
Excuse me.
Young lady.
You know you have to pay for those.
Hey, stop.
Please.
You have to pay for those.
Stop right there.
Thief, thief.
(glass shatters)
♪ And you ♪
♪ You will be queen ♪
♪ Though nothing ♪
♪ Will drive us away ♪
♪ We can be heroes ♪
♪ Just for one day ♪
- Everything I said about you
being a traitor and stuff.
I was wrong.
I'm sorry.
- Friends?
♪ I ♪
♪ I can remember ♪
- Goodbye, Mike.
♪ Standing ♪
♪ Standing by the wall ♪
♪ And the guns ♪
♪ Shot above our heads ♪
- No more.
♪ And we kissed ♪
(monster screams)